[Música]
bienvenidos a la serie en france24 mi
nombre es ligan a valencia y hoy les
damos la bienvenida a una serie
justamente de informes especiales acerca
de la principal o las independencias que
tuvo lugar en el continente africano en
el año de 1960 por eso justamente en
2020 se conmemoran los 60 años de las
independencias en 17 países africanos 14
de ellos antiguas colonias francesas que
hoy trabaja por consolidar su autonomía
esta hora de independencia su lugar
después de la segunda guerra mundial
frente a una europa debilitada veamos en
nuestra pantalla de los 17 países que
están conmemorando su aniversario
independentista camerún para el primer
país africano en lograr la independencia
en el año de 1960 el primero de enero
todo el 27 de abril la federación de
malí el 20 de junio la república
democrática del congo se independizó de
bélgica el 29 de junio
somalia se independizó del reino unido
el primero de julio siguieron también
venir el primero de agosto
níger el 3 de agosto burkina faso el 5
de agosto costa de marfil el 7 de agosto
chad el 11 de agosto la república
centroafricana el 13 de agosto
saville el 15 de agosto gabor el 17 de
agosto y posteriormente nigeria se
independizó de reino unido el primero de
octubre mauritaria obtuvo su
independencia el 28 de noviembre de 1960
iniciamos esta serie de informes
especiales con la independencia de malí
una particularmente compleja que
redibujó las fronteras de áfrica
occidental dos países senegal y sudán
francés se unieron para formar la
federación de malí que se independizó de
francia el 20 de junio de 1960 pero que
se opusieron dos visiones
irreconciliables de la cooperación con
la antigua colonia y dos meses más tarde
senegal y el antiguo sudán francés
terminaron por separarse veamos la
historia
el 20 de junio de 1960 en dakar los
colores franceses dan paso a los de un
nuevo estado la federación de mar y
reúne dos antiguas colonias del áfrica
occidental francesa senegal y sudán
francesa
el ministro de estado luis aquino el
senegalés mamadou día y el sudanés
modibo keita realizan la transferencia
de competencias firmada el 4 de abril en
parís bajo la mirada del líder senegalés
léopold sédar senghor quien negoció
previamente con charles de gaulle
esa misma noche la asamblea federal de
malí votó de manera unánime por la
independencia
pero las celebraciones no duraron mucho
muy rápidamente se pusieron dos visiones
encarnadas por dos personalidades los
pueblos engorde aboga por la consulta
con francia cuando modibo keita adquiere
un estado fuerte y pan africano
[Música]
carisma el activismo por sí solo es un
estímulo para poblaciones que durante
mucho tiempo tuvieron una vida puramente
rural fibroma o rural el 18 de agosto
modibo keita nombra unilateralmente jefe
de estado mayor del ejército al coronel
abdullah ya su madre
[Música]
en respuesta leopold senghor decretó el
estado de emergencia arrestó a su madre
y escoltó a modibo keita hasta la
frontera el día 20 la asamblea de dakar
votó por la independencia de senegal
como entidad única
los sudaneses soñaban con un estado
unitario en el que no se hubieran
dominado gracias a su número y
disciplina queríamos un estado federal
muy flexible soñaban con concentra la
mayor parte del poder federal en manos
de un solo hombre queríamos un sistema
democrático de los poderes para
colaborar fueran compartidos
equilibrados
colabore de ese equilibrio un mes
después el sudan francés a su vez
proclama su independencia manteniendo la
referencia al glorioso imperio de maddie
uno de los más antiguos del continente
bajo el liderazgo de modibo keita en la
república de malí nació el 22 de
septiembre de 1960
pero francia no fue la única potencia
colonizadora del continente africano a
la búsqueda de materias primas y
africanos esclavizados para trabajar en
las plantaciones en américa los europeos
se vivieron el territorio africano a
finales del siglo 19 el pequeño reino de
bélgica logró imponer su dominio en el
congo el segundo país más grande de
áfrica
después de haber sido colonizado durante
75 años por los belgas fue precisamente
a las 11 de la mañana del 29 de junio de
1960 cuando se proclamó la independencia
de la república democrática del congo en
1885 el rey de bélgica leopoldo segundo
hizo de este vasto y rico territorio su
propiedad privada y no fue sino hasta
1908 que se convirtió en colonia belga
en kinshasa en su discurso en 1960 el
rey baduino primero elogió los méritos
de la colonización inmediatamente
después la respuesta del primer ministro
congoleño patrice lumumba fue mordaz
hemos conocido las ironías los insultos
los golpes que tuvimos que sufrir mañana
mediodía y noche nuestras series están
todavía demasiado frescas para que
podamos sacarlas de nuestra memoria
durante décadas la explotación de caucho
en el congo y luego de las minas
enriquecieron a los belgas debido a la
explotación atroz y asesina la población
se redujo de 20 millones de personas en
1885 a 10 millones en 1908
bélgica afirma haber concedido la
independencia al congo pero en realidad
los movimientos de resistencia contra el
colonialismo fueron los que lograron la
emancipación
los belgas hicieron todo lo posible para
evitar la constitución de una elite
congoleña durante la colonia
el resultado fue cruel cuando llegó la
independencia muy pocos congoleños
estaban capacitados para administrar la
nación patrice lumumba fue arrestado en
diciembre y ejecutado en enero de 1961
muchos historiadores ven la mano de la
cia y de bélgica detrás de su magnicidio
hoy en día muchos congoleños creen que
la independencia se produjo de manera
apresurada y que fue torpedeada por los
belgas de estos movimientos de
independencia surgieron líderes
africanos notables uno de los más
grandes iconos de la libertad del
continente africano fue el comandante
thomas sankara también conocido como el
che guevara africano por sus ideales
para africanistas
es el 5 de agosto de 1960 los
principales líderes africanos y
franceses se reúnen para asistir a un
momento histórico la independencia de la
república de alto volta
[Música]
el nuevo presidente de maurice yaméogo
planta un árbol para simbolizar la
independencia y las esperanzas de toda
una nación
[Música]
mis compatriotas el 5 de agosto de 1960
a la medianoche el nombre del derecho
humano natural la libertad la igualdad y
la fraternidad proclamó solemnemente la
independencia de la república de alto
con el mal n penas de la république de
vuelta
de 1890 tanto francia como gran bretaña
se habían embarcado en una conquista de
áfrica cientos de soldados entraron en
los reinos musique dejando un rastro de
destrucción detrás de ellos
después de la conquista inicial el
protectorado de uagadugú se convirtió en
parte del áfrica occidental francesa
durante la primera guerra mundial
los combatientes moss y se convirtieron
en una parte integral de los batallones
africanos que luchar por francia en 1919
francia decidió crear el alto volta
francés pero para reforzar su autoridad
el poder colonizador desmanteló el
territorio en varias partes después de
la segunda guerra mundial el país
recuperó su unidad y junto con sus
países vecinos alto volta se unió a la
unión francesa cumpliendo la visión de
charles de gaulle después de la
independencia el presidente llame o
prohibió todos los partidos políticos
excepto el suyo seis años más tarde un
movimiento masivo popular lo sacó del
poder en 1983 un golpe militar llevó al
gran comandante tomás es tan cara al
poder que en cambio el nombre del país
de alto volta burkina faso que significa
tierra de hombres son es el primero de
octubre de 1960 nigeria se independizó
del reino unido en medio de intensos
conflictos entre regiones separatistas
que llevaron a una grave crisis
humanitaria hoy junto con sudáfrica de
gigante económico del continente
africano
el país más poblado de áfrica se
independizó del reino unido el primero
de octubre de 1960 los colonos
británicos llegaron a nigeria en la
década de 1850 la educación colonialista
impartida por misioneros cristianos
encontró una fuerte resistencia
especialmente de los líderes musulmanes
en el norte del país durante la
colonización el sur se desarrollo más
rápidamente que el norte esta división
tuvo consecuencias después de la
independencia los primeros movimientos
nacionalistas aparecen en la década de
1920 durante las siguientes cuatro
décadas la lucha contra la dominación
colonial continuó creciendo hasta lograr
la libertad total de la explotación
británica del territorio y el capital
humano después de la independencia
estallaron conflictos interétnicos entre
los causa en el norte y los vivos en el
este el jefe de este pueblo se llamaba
mk ocupo
si estalla una guerra civil y creo que
es inminente
ese será el precio a pagar por nuestra
libertad
en mayo de 1967 declaró la independencia
de la república de biafra en el este la
guerra civil comienza en julio
y sus tropas se enfrentan al ejército y
al líder nigeriano yakubu común
y los sacrificios serán altos pero la
causa es justa y loable viva la
federación de nigeria y la guerra de
biafra duró hasta 1970 dejando miles de
víctimas como consecuencia de los
injustos repartos europeos de los
territorios africanos que dejaron grupos
étnicos enemigos dentro de las mismas
fronteras fue después de haber vivido
estos hechos que un grupo de
trabajadores humanitarios decidió fundar
la famosa ong médicos sin fronteras y
finalizamos esta serie con mauritania
que celebró los 60 años de su
independencia el 28 de noviembre desde
2020 por último de los 17 países
africanos independizarse en el año de
1960 la región donde se encuentra la
actual mauritania ha sido desde siempre
un punto de unión entre el magreb y el
áfrica sub-sahariana los franceses
llegaron a la zona a finales del siglo
19 en 1903 mauritania se convirtió en
protectorado francés y luego en colonia
seis décadas después moctar ould daddah
proclamó la independencia del país el 28
de noviembre de 1960 la capital era
una ciudad recién creada para entonces
el país casi no tenía infraestructura
porque los colonos franceses de la
región habían desarrollado
principalmente la ciudad senegalesa de
san luis ubicada un poco más al sujeto
millones habló la capital de las urnas
república islámica de mauritania
mauritania tiene un millón de kilómetros
cuadrados y dos tercios del país se
encuentran en pleno desierto del sahara
moctar all that a tenía para entonces
una ardua tarea de construir un estado
una unidad nacional y una economía en
1960 los ingresos de la nación dependían
de la explotación del hierro y del
sector agro pastoral políticamente
mauritania ha experimentado una serie de
golpes militares desde la independencia
en este enorme país donde viven 4
millones de personas la primera
transición pacífica del poder tuvo lugar
apenas en 2019
así finalizamos este capítulo de la
serie en brands 24 ustedes pueden
continuar con más información en nuestra
página web france24 puntocom nos vemos
más adelante con más información de
américa latina y el mundo quédense con
nosotros
[Música]